- That day, when the bus
driver asked me to get up,
I had this feeling come over me,
it felt like Harriet
Tubman was holding me down,
hands were holding me down on one shoulder
and Sojourner Truth hands
were holding me down
on another shoulder,
and I was glued to the
seat and I could hear
the white passengers
saying, "She gotta move,
she gotta move.”
"That's the law, she gotta move."
and I felt like,
this is my time to take
a stand for justice.
(laughs)
My name is Claudette Colvin,
and in 1955 I refused to give up my seat
to a white passenger on the
bus in Montgomery, Alabama,
nine months before Rosa Parks.
I was 15 years old, and the
rule and the segregation
that a white person had
to sit in front of you
and you sit behind them,
and so the bus driver asked me to get up.
I was shouting, it's my
constitutional rights,
I'm not gonna move,
and that's when the policeman
dragged me off the bus.
Most people ask me, weren't you afraid?
Well, I was a teenager, I was afraid,
but I was more angry at
these white passengers.
And then, they took me and booked me.
I still vividly can hear
the sound of the keys go,
(makes turning sounds)
and I was terrified
and I starting reciting
the Lord's Prayer.
"Thou will be done on
Earth as it is in Heaven."
And I was just praying for help,
you know, praying that they were
going to let my parents know
that I was in jail.
My mom would say, "Claudette,
I think you was anointed
by God to do this."
I said, “I don't think so mother,
I just had, I just thought
that this was my right.”
I just wanted people to
come together and unify
and fight the segregation.
(upbeat music)